hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar enabling sequencing applications
with improved transpose-based Solutions
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by SQL
to learn more please visit sequel.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd now like to welcome our speakers
Joseph C Miller PhD co-founder and chief
scientific officer at SQL Curtis Knox
director of product management at sequel
and Jessica M Smith PhD director of
bioinformatics at SQL Jessica I'll now
pass it over to you to get us started
hi everyone Thanks for tuning in my name
is Jessica Smith I'm the director of
bioinformatics here at SQL and I'm also
our moderator for today's discussion on
transpose-based Library Technologies
SQL was created to revolutionize NGS
Library prep to unlock the full
potential of today's DNA sequencing
instruments and today's topic is
critical to optimizing that potential
tn5 has become an integral component of
NGS Library prep its unique capabilities
have unlocked a plethora of recent
advancements now at the Forefront of
biomedical research and development
I'm joined today by two of my colleagues
Joe mellor sql's co-founder and chief
scientific officer and Curtis Knox our
director of product management
thank you both for being here thanks
Jess thanks Jess great so let's get into
today's presentation which we've
entitled enabling sequencing
applications with improved
transpose-based Solutions
Curtis can you tell us a little bit more
about what our audience can expect sure
by the end of this discussion we hope
that our viewers will be able to First
understand how tagmentation can work
across a wide variety of NGS
applications secondly we want them to
understand how transpose ace-based NGS
Library prep methods
can result in significant workflow
improvements and then lastly we think
that they'll be able to understand how
some custom tn5 loaded
reagents can create opportunities for
them for new Innovations in their
laboratory and be able to do all of this
without compromising their data thanks
Curtis it sounds like there's a lot of
ways that this enzyme can maximize the
potential of NGS Library prep so I'm
really looking forward to today's
discussion Joe do you want to give us a
little background on tn5 in NGS sure I'd
be glad to I think it's helpful for us
to start with an overview really of
where the sequencing arena is uh today
uh the you know the growth of sequencers
uh has become so prolific we are now
using instruments that are orders of
magnitude higher throughput and larger
than they were even a few years ago and
because of that sequencing has really
become a universal tool in life science
research not just for sequencing genomes
in other samples but really for a
variety of types of measurement of
biological assays and you know I think
it's important to point out that the the
cost and time associated with getting
samples to those sequencers which we
call library prep has really lagged
behind and has not Advanced uh and kept
up really with the tremendous
improvements in sequencer throughput
so sequel's Mission really is to focus
on that bottleneck how to create the
tools that will enable researchers and
and users of sequencers to get their
samples to sequencers more efficiently
and uh in many cases that means we
enable higher multiplexing of more
samples and simpler workflows to allow
samples to be processed more quickly and
efficiently wonderful thank you thank
you for that background I think it
really does sort of set the stage for
this conversation do you want to get
into a little more detail about the
biology of tan 5 sure so you know I
think what you'll hear today really is
is that tn5 is a centerpiece of most of
our products here at SQL because it's an
extremely versatile and simple tool for
helping scale a number of NGS workflows
before we get into those products though
I think it's helpful for us to maybe
take a little bit of a step back and and
talk about the history of tn5 tm5 has
been around for you know a few decades
now has been highly characterized has a
number of really interesting properties
that owe to its sort of natural
capability of of being part of a
transposon transposons are mobile
genetic elements and genomes and this
enzyme was evolved essentially the the
capability of allowing that DNA to
transfer around inside a genome thank
you for giving us a little bit of
history about tn5 and its biology now
can you go into a little more depth
about how tn5 is useful for NGS
applications sure so I think you know
there's a few really interesting
properties about tn5 that make it a
really versatile enzyme for NGS I think
uh probably the most important is that
it being a an enzyme that's capable of
really binding and inserting DNA nearly
randomly in any Target sequence allows
it to be sort of substituted for
protocols that need a shotgun
fragmentation like a function another
really interesting property of the
enzyme is that it can be functionalized
loaded with uh you know different types
of payload which we have turned into the
ability to put different sequencing type
functions into it such as sequencing
adapters finally I think the other piece
that we'll talk about today is that the
enzyme is got a property that allows it
to be exploited as a normalization agent
because its function is to do do its job
and do it one time only and therefore
controlling the amount of enzyme can
control the number of reactions that
occur in in a in a typical reaction wow
well this sounds like a system with a
lot of potential
um so Curtis I'm going to ask you to
tell us a little bit more about the
various ways that we can use this
technology in different NGS Library prep
applications sure so Joe talked about
the biology of the enzyme itself and
what I want to talk about a little bit
is how we've used that to create
NGS Library prep methods and products
that really help the users when it comes
to getting the most efficiency out of
you know what they're trying to do so
what we've done is create a series of
methods and products that allow for what
we refer to as true multiplexing so much
higher levels of samples that can be
multiplexed together for their
sequencing and we do this through a
method in which we're utilizing
asymmetric tagging of the libraries
adding the i7 section and the I5 section
in sequential fashion and that allows
really nice control allows normalization
that Joe alluded to and
has high efficiency for converting the
DNA into actual sequencing libraries and
so as an example here when we think
about traditional ligation or other
types of methods you're typically
looking at five and a half six hours or
more to do a plate of 96 samples with
our methods using tn5 transpose Ace
we've gotten that down to right now
three and a half or less hours to do
that full plate of samples and at the
same time creating some of those extra
bonus features like the normalization
that we talked to and these have a wide
range of applications everything from
whole genome sequencing low pass
genotyping microbial and metagenomic
sequencing and even single cell rna-seq
from there
yeah interesting so you mentioned
normalization as a bonus but it actually
seems pretty Central to a lot of the
products that we sell can you um go into
a little more depth about this unique
capability and give us maybe an example
of one of our products that leverages
sure so the first thing I'd like to you
know maybe use is that example exactly
is our Pure Plex DNA Library prep kit
that we just released earlier in 2022
and this is one where we've taken those
features and actually improved the
workflow down to as little as two and a
half hours when it comes to that and
we've also Incorporated unique dual
indices into that particular kit so
that's something that we've heard from
users that they're looking for extra
control of their samples and you know
data quality and everything else from
there so the incorporation of the udis
has been very important as well and that
is a product that currently we have with
192 different UD apis we plan to expand
that up to about 384 in the near future
as well great so you mentioned briefly
that
udis have something to do with data
quality do you want to like clarify that
a little bit sure so when you think
about
uh making sure that the sequences that
you get are definitively coming from
each of your samples that you're
interested in because those samples all
get pulled together on the sequencer and
it's very important that you be able to
assign those reads exactly back to the
sample of Interest utilizing a unique
dual indices allows you to make sure
that you're you're fully separating that
data out and have the highest confidence
we've started talking a little bit about
how our multiplexing capabilities can
lead to improved performance so Joe do
you want to give us an example about
this and about how normalization Works
in practice sure so yeah the idea of
normalization is is that in many
sequencing workflows
um you know the user the researcher has
their sample and maybe it's present in
different amounts and uh so it's a
difficult problem and Labs spend a lot
of time with this and the way that our
chemistry works is that it facilitates a
sequential tagging process where the
first tagging event is used as a way of
specifying the number of molecules that
can be generated and then we pull that
material together or in the case of pure
Plex we have a different method for
accomplishing this to then turn those
first tagging instances into a
normalized library where all of those
samples are represented with the same
number of reads so what you can see in
this example where we can take tenfold
range of DNA amount and generate a
consistent amount of library from that
and you know this is a really useful
thing for many people who you know
otherwise would have to take those
samples and either individually Quant
and adjust them or make libraries and
then normalize them afterward the point
is is with our chemistries this process
is highly simplified and we've removed
for many people this need to do a
separate normalization step yeah
yeah a lot of different researchers and
clinical applications where this would
be really useful so do you want to give
us an example of how our Multiplex
workflows are used in the real world
sure I think there's no better example
in the last couple of years than Labs
that have had to scale up for example
the ability to sequence covet genomes
you know we you know I think all of us
woke up to a need really overnight
starting two years ago where we wanted
to be able to track and and characterize
different variants of of you know SARS
cov2 genome that was emerging and uh an
example of this type of work it was a
collaboration we did with a group at
t-gen in Arizona where essentially
overnight we help them stand up a
coveted sequencing effort where they
could take their coveted positive
specimens and reflex them into a
sequencing assay and track those
variants in real time to better
understand what was going on with the
spread of the virus and new variants
and you know I think this is a great
example where a lab was able to go from
doing zero this type of sample to
thousands per week uh in a matter of a
few weeks that's a that's a really great
example of how the power of this kind of
Technology now let's look ahead at some
like new products we have Curtis do you
want to tell us about what's coming down
the pipeline well I think first uh maybe
you know Joe if you'd like to touch on
some of the rapid uh you know single
cell RNA rna-seq applications and then
you know we can follow that up with some
of the really exciting stuff that we've
got coming down the pike here yeah
absolutely so you know I think
um as we've sort of taken the Plex ball
and pureplex Technologies sort of as the
basis and foundation for other types of
assays that we can build we look for uh
applications where this need to
Multiplex or essentially process large
numbers of samples is really important
and I think one really good example of
this is in single cell sequencing
especially single cell RNA seek and
again here what we did is we
collaborated with a researcher who
specializes in this type of assay was
actually the inventor of a method called
smart seek two about 10 years ago Simone
pacelli and we created a kit that allows
for this sort of integrated processing
of single cells through to a sequencer
ready rna-seq library and essentially a
single day and I think the the story of
this product is really that we were able
to take the Plex Bill technology and
combine it with a high performance
chemistry to to essentially take RNA
from cells and turn it into the DNA that
becomes the input to our plexible kit
which has again this uh really important
property of normalizing for the
differences that might exist between
those samples and so if you look at the
performance of this product this is
where it really shines again in a
conventional sort of setting the
researcher would have this problem of
having some cells generate more data
than other cells and they would have
dropouts for example with Plex well this
problem is significantly improved
because you get again a greater
performance across a greater number of
samples and essentially more sequencing
data from more cells in the same assay
and I guess the final piece of this is
that we do this at really no ultimate
cost to the actual sequencing
performance itself we you know it's a
workflow Improvement it's certainly uh
enables the multiplexing side of this
but if it produced worse data this would
not obviously be a great solution we
know for scientists and and so we've
benchmarked this and we see that again
we can have this really nice
normalization without any real cost in
terms of the the metrics associated with
detecting RNA from cells great wow well
I mean between the covid stuff and the
Single Cell work that you just described
it seems like a lot of solutions are
being generated by our company I'd love
to hear about what sorts of things were
going to help other researchers sure so
there's some really exciting stuff
coming down the pike including uh what
we're referring to now as expressplex
which is something that we have in Early
Access at the moment and we'll be
rolling out to users in the near future
and this is by far the fastest overall
NGS Library prep method out there to be
capable of this true multiplexing and
high levels of Multiplex that we've
talked about and in this particular
method you literally are mixing your DNA
a tagging reagent and a master mix
you're putting those three things
together putting on the thermocycler for
an hour and then your pooling and doing
one cleanup and in 90 minutes flat you
have 96 samples ready to go all barcode
voted and ready to pull and put in your
thermocycler and we can continue that
barcoding multiplexing aspect upwards we
anticipate you know 768 barcodes in the
near future moving that upwards to 1536
and Beyond as necessary from the users
as we find that out so we're really
excited to bring this to customers in
the very near future
wow wonderful thank you so much for
explaining a little bit about our
technology Express Plex but going back a
little bit more to the transposase
itself are there any ways that we're
leveraging that technology to do
multiple different applications sure so
that's a great uh segue into talking
about something that we're referring to
as tagify which is a tn5 transpose Ace
based kind of toolbox for lack of a
better phrase in which we are going to
help users and researchers out there
utilize the power of transpose-based
methods and enable different types of
Innovations
utilizing the enzyme along with some
different tags to actually achieve new
things and that can be something like
crispr verifications it can be looking
at variations where we're enabling
ligation methods we have unique
molecular identifier methods and
versions of this in which we're loading
on sequences that will allow customers
and users to really be able to hone in
exactly down to almost a molecular level
and look at the sequences that are
coming through it's a super exciting uh
new thing that we're pushing into to
help enable users to really create even
more innovation in their Laboratory
cool well it's like really wonderful
that we have this really flexible
transpose ace-based offering I wonder
Joe if you have a little bit more to say
about so the application areas and the
technical details about what we can do
to help our customers yeah absolutely
and as Curtis mentioned we're working in
this uh tagify Arena it's really about
creating tools that again our users and
and those researchers can take and plug
into assays that they're trying to build
you know again we realize we we have
some great products that help in
multiplexing and but again some of these
are also just basic tools that can help
build the next generation of
multiplexing tools and one great example
of this is is again the crispr QC
methods which benefit uh often from
being able to put a sort of molecular
counter into the reagent that's being
used to generate a library
again there's other ways of doing this
again the the tried and true way that
this field has used for many years is to
do a fragmentation and ligation-based
assay and again this is a great example
where a transpose dates can come in and
take what was previously several
distinct steps in a workflow and replace
it with a single step that has equally
high performance and again simpler
workflow and and more predictable
performance so I think we're really you
know again excited to work with people
in this field you know we see that again
for this field to mature there's going
to need to be more tools and and we're
really excited to have the opportunity
to to be involved in building those
tools you mentioned more tools and I I
should be clear that most of the work
that we've talked about so far has been
on aluminum platforms everyone knows
Illumina but we also know that there are
more tools coming into the sequencer
space too so do we have any plans to
integrate our library prep with those
other sequencers absolutely yeah
definitely and this is a really exciting
area I mean I think the history of NGS
till this point has really been the
story of one very dominant sequencing
platform which has really built this
Market but we now see again and I think
it's exciting uh the emergence of other
sequencing platforms
um with you know again a slightly
different chemistry slightly different
abilities that are going to give
researchers and NGS users more choice
and what types of of platform but also
you know really specifically tuned
perhaps to certain assays that they want
to run I think we've been very excited
uh to to start to work with some of
these newer platforms and for example we
collaborated with Sean Levy and his team
at element bioscience to validate our
plexible technology on their new avidi
sequencer
and again we're very excited to see this
technology and and we see that it
certainly has a couple of benefits over
existing sequencing Platforms in terms
of its flexibility and cost and some you
know metrics that are important such as
duplication rates and so on as these
Technologies progress and other
sequencers are made available we're
certainly I think going to be in a good
position to use some of the same Library
prep technologies that we've built into
our kits and we think multiplexing will
be an important part of all these
platforms uh we know that you know again
users and scientists simply want to be
able to run more samples and and do so
more reliably and so we're very excited
about that
oh wonderful I mean I I helped out a
little bit with some of the element work
and I have to say the metrics that came
off were really impressive I really I
thought it was really interesting uh to
be to be working on
um all right guys I'm going to let you
both say at least one more thing about
transposes and Library prep if you'd
like so um Joe I'll let you go first
yeah yeah I think uh you know again for
us um you know as you've probably
learned today and again hopefully our
audience has learned the tn5 transpose
Ace is a real centerpiece for our work
in building better NGS workflows and we
think it has some intrinsic benefits
that for example enable more scalable
performance and again inherently sort of
address some of the core issues that you
know users face every day like how to
process more samples save time and money
and effort associated with things like
normalization
and I think what you're going to see
from SQL as time goes on is again we're
going to be taking some of the same
approaches we've taken to date in in
terms of taking workflows that would
otherwise be more complicated or take
more time for a user and and and and
build workflows that essentially uh
remove steps or simplify steps for
example with new formulations of these
enzymes combining them with other
enzymes as we learned about today with
expressplex again very exciting product
where we're able to essentially do many
things in one reaction mixture I think
this is going to be a familiar theme and
sort of how we engineer workflows to do
you know the next generation of assays
and certainly as far as the the tn5
enzyme itself which is really the star
of our show I think you know we're very
excited on all of the improvements that
we see that lie ahead in terms of what
we can do with that enzyme
yeah and I would just add to that uh you
know hopefully people have seen and can
maybe understand that we're really still
scratching the surface there's still a
lot of improvements a lot of
advancements that we're continuing to
make using tn5 transpose a says the the
base module for that and it's not just
about what we produce and put it in a
box it's really about helping our
researchers and you know our
collaborators to make new Innovations
and to do great science so you know we'd
encourage anybody who's interested in
learning more about this or wants to
talk about a project and say what if you
know reach out to us you know we'd love
to have that conversation with you and
see if we can't help
great well thank you both for today's
informative presentation thanks Jess
it's been great yeah thanks Jess really
appreciate it and another huge thank you
to our audience for tuning in feel free
to reach out and let us know what you
found most interesting about this
discussion we would love to hear from
you
can also connect with SQL online at
sequel.com to find additional resources
on this topic and others and of course
don't forget to follow us on your
favorite social media platform
once again I'm Jessica Smith director of
bioinformatics at Sequel and this has
been enabling sequencing applications
with improved transpose-based Solutions
well thank you again Joe and Curtis for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
all right so let's get started
our first question here asks how is
sql's tagmentation technology different
from others currently available
yeah so thank you very much Kaylee and
uh yeah we'll be glad to answer that I
think you know the the the simple I
think answer there is that our ability
to create uh you know tn5 reagents that
are loaded with you know payloads that
enable multiplexing is is is based on
you know a number of things one is uh
first of all you know the the indexed uh
tn5 reagents that are built into the
products that you heard about today like
Plex well pure Plex and expressplex and
also again some some of them were
cutting edge applications uh such as you
know the Umi uh based method that we
talked about in in crispr QC I think
it's uh it's our you know sort of
strength there and being able to create
those you know reagents that are enabled
for specific applications and with
different payloads that go far beyond
really the uh the you know sort of
non-index form of of tagmentation
Technology that's been available uh
previously so that that would be really
I think the the short answer on that
great thank you next question here asks
tn5 transpose a sometimes or seems to
have a lot of applications are there
areas where tagmentation is not
appropriate
yes so that's a great question and again
thank you for uh for whoever I asked it
I yeah I think it you know there's
there's certainly areas where uh you
know tagmentation has um historically
not been you know the preferred approach
uh you know I think uh you know
difficult sample types extremely low
input DNA sample types again these
tend to be uh you know the domain of of
of of more ligation-based strategies
instead of using a transpose Ace
um but that said I think you know what
what we have certainly seen is that you
know there is a a great number of
applications where you know a tn5
transpose days can uh be appropriate and
you know so I think you know we're we're
always interested even for those
difficult problems in in in and seeing
if we can make a transpose a space tool
that's appropriate
um and you know I think uh for those
challenging sample types I think you
know uh certainly more work to be done
but we're you know we're certainly
excited about the potential there uh
going forward
great thank you Joe
I have another question Joe for you here
this question asks what is the
performance of tn5 in low and high GC
regions
again thanks for the question and uh you
know I think
what we have looked at um and I I'll
tell you you know just based on our
experience with uh with our products uh
using the the transpose Ace you know
there's certainly a a wide range of of
GC tolerance when we look for example at
microbial specimens
um that are as low as let's say 30 GC up
to 70 GC in some ways this is the
hardest stress test you can give a
library prep because it's very difficult
sometimes to get equal performance
across that wider range uh and and you
know this has honestly been one of the I
think the real success cases for our
product is is being able to you know be
used pretty seamlessly in a wide range
of microbial applications that again
span a wide range of GC
um you know again I think there's always
I think uh some concern about you know
the bias or or your performance of the
tn5 transpose days but again in in most
applications we see that this is is
um you know something that you know we
we do not see impacting the performance
um for for you know most sequencing
workflows
um that require you know standard depth
coverage
great thank you next question Joe
another one for you where do we see some
of the newer sequencing platforms using
tn5 based technology to scale up larger
volume projects
yeah again thank you for the question I
think you know here what I would point
to is you know some of the intrinsic
benefits that we mentioned in our you
know conversation uh today such as
workflow I think you know the trend with
uh some of the newer sequencing
platforms that uh are now um uh arising
you know very exciting uh times really
in the sequencing World seeing new
platforms with uh you know increased
throughput and lower cost you know again
multiplexing is is a core piece of that
and and the workflow uh to enable that
work you know multiplexing is also
extremely important I think tm5 is a as
a kind of Workhorse enzyme there is is
really critical because it has this
workflow Advantage um over you know what
we would call conventional
ligation-based Library technology again
uh you know there are simply you know um
uh numerous you know time and cost
saving advantages that
um will I think give the tn5 based
approaches I think a bit of an edge when
it comes to uh really looking at how
we're going to take advantage of these
new platforms and their you know they're
they're really promising multiplexing
capacity and again I think you know
we're excited about you know the
opportunity to uh help build some of
those tools
great thank you Joe
all right we're getting some great
questions in from our audience
we're going to go ahead and proceed here
this next question asks I'd like to get
in touch with SQL to discuss a custom
project how would I do this
well I'll take that one and I get the
easy one after Joe gets all the the
tough questions here uh as it uh I don't
know if the screen is still showing with
the final slide there but the easiest
way would just be to email us at info
sql.com and let us know uh if there's
something of interest uh that you'd like
to discuss as far as a project uh you
can also check out some of the
information on our website as as Jess uh
alluded to earlier including a landing
page for expressplex if you're
interested in checking that out under
the products uh
menu if you will and then you can just
let us know what you're interested in if
there are specific tagify related
projects that you would like to to
discuss we're happy to hop on a call and
learn more about your needs and you know
there's a good chance that we have a
solution that may work for you already
uh from there and then
um you know we can we can help out and
really learn more about what you're
doing and we we love to you know get
some collaboration with that so
great thank you Curtis
we have another question here for Joe
how do you see tagmentation or tn5
working with those who want to do
expression rna-seq or single cell
yeah a great question and again thanks I
think you know there's a lot of history
here where uh you know tm5 transposes
has already really been shown to be a
great tool for this um again
historically methods such as smart seek
2 and you know related High throughput
rna-seq assays have heavily relied on
this enzyme
um you know as I showed I think in a
couple of our slides and discussion
today there's certainly I think
tremendous potential impact here where
you know again we can help improve some
of the either multiplexing uh throughput
and you know being able to run more
samples more easily uh or again even I
think in a more exciting fashion you
know take those workflows and compress
them I think one of the challenges with
a number of especially rna-seq uh
workflows is is that you you know
sometimes have protocols that can take
you know researchers uh a long time
sometimes more than a day and again
we're very excited uh you know to again
take some of the the tools we've built
and applied them to rnac and that you're
going to certainly see I think more to
come from us in this Dimension uh soon
uh but you know I think that this is an
area where again some of the workflow
innovations that we've created are going
to have a tremendous impact
great
well thank you again Joe and Curtis for
your time today and your important
research we're going to go ahead and
wrap up here so I would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor SQL for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye